the jedi order rebels tie-ins and an
ominously familiar sith the first
trailer for obi-wan kenobi is here did
you catch these little details
if you know why obi-wan is on tatooine
you might have expected this detail but
it is nonetheless cool to see in the
teaser we get a glimpse of obi-wan
observing uncle owen and amber roo from
some high ground and sure enough the
jedi's binoculars settle on what appears
to be a young luke skywalker pretending
to pod race as star wars fans know very
well obi-wan's task is to protect him at
all cost and this appearance of luke
certainly gives us a lot of information
as to how many years have passed since
the events of revenge of the sith based
on what we can see luke seems to be
about 10 years old this means that the
events of obi-wan kenobi will likely be
picking up not too long after revenge of
the sith it'll be interesting to see how
obi-wan manages his duty of protecting
luke while remaining out of sight either
way obi-wan kenobi promises to bring
greater insight into the young luke's
life on tatooine even if luke himself
only features briefly
in the new teaser trailer perhaps one of
the first things that strikes fans of
star wars is the ominous and immediately
recognizable soundtrack this is of
course the john williams masterpiece
from star wars the phantom menace called
duel of the fates duel of the fates was
previously used during the epic
confrontation between obi-wan qui-gon
jinn and darth maul in the first movie
of the prequel trilogy its usage in the
obi-wan trailer pays tribute to this
earlier struggle but at this point it
seems that the point is to more squarely
focus on the past and future of what we
want as he struggles to find his fate in
a galaxy that seeks his death
it seems like the obi-wan kenobi series
is gunning for more than your everyday
tie-ins to the films because the new
trailer also shows off several of the
infamous inquisitors the inquisitors for
those who missed out on the tv series
star wars rebels are a group of force
sensitives enlisted by the empire to
hunt down the remaining jedi personally
trained by darth vader and formerly jedi
themselves the inquisitors play a large
part in further eradicating the jedi in
the years following order 66. throughout
the trailer we are shown three different
inquisitors two of which have appeared
in previous star wars stories the first
of these is the grand inquisitor an
ex-jedi pow-on with white skin and
distinctive face markings he plays an
important role as a primary villain
throughout much of rebels as well as in
several comics the other known
inquisitor is the fifth brother who was
also a common sight in rebels as a minor
villain the only inquisitor we don't
know much about is riva played by moses
ingram who we see getting involved in a
number of tense confrontations
throughout the trailer based on this
it's clear that the inquisitors are set
to play a major role as antagonists
throughout the series potentially
crossing sabers with obi-wan though
given that obi-wan manages to make it to
a new hope alive that may not go half as
well as they think
the universe of star wars is filled with
strange and amazing animals and some
humanoids that straddle the line between
person and animal looking at you chewie
looks crazy obi-wan himself is no
stranger to hanging out with the
menagerie of space beasts having ridden
everything from varactols to iowa over
the years in the obi-wan trailer the
character is shown riding something that
appears to be a camel this might strike
the casual star wars fan off guard after
all there's no way a star wars show
would put a camel on tatooine no camels
han solo is right it isn't a camel it's
actually a four-legged herbivore known
as an eop originally from tatooine their
adaptations to the harsh environment
make them very useful for carrying
luggage or people across the desert you
know just like the camels in our world
the nostalgia is strong with this one at
one point during the new obi-wan trailer
fans are greeted by the return
appearance of actor joel edgerton's
uncle owen character who many star wars
fans will remember served as anakin
skywalker's stepbrother in episode 2
attack of the clones and luke
skywalker's guardian on tatooine at the
end of revenge of the sith not
surprisingly fans are psyched in the
obi-wan trailer the show's big new bad
riva the inquisitor comes face to face
with edgerton's owen after arriving on
tatooine with her evil empire cronies
actor bonnie peace who played uncle
owen's girlfriend in episodes two and
three is also set to appear as her aunt
peru character as fans know the two
characters are fated to be tragically
killed off in a new hope by imperial
stormtroopers but this will mark the
first time we truly see what their life
while raising the future jedi hero was
like while the obi-wan kenobi teaser
trailer was packed to the brim with
references and epic glimpses of things
to come there's one little moment that
appears so briefly that only die-hard
fans would notice it on the first watch
at one point an unknown hand touches
what appears to be a symbol carved into
a wall which appears to be the official
jedi order crest a lightsaber with
elaborate wings on either side it's
crudely carved but it's an important
symbol for the jedi order serving as an
official insignia for them for thousands
of years before their eventual fall it
being carved into the wall like graffiti
is an indicator perhaps that hope for
the return of the jedi remains strong
that said because this moment is so
brief there is no definitive evidence
that this is the crest of the jedi order
and it could be something else entirely
while darth vader doesn't physically
appear in the obi-wan kenobi limited
series teaser trailer his presence looms
large and fans who listen carefully can
hear vader's iconic breathing at the
very end of the teaser trailer hayden
christensen who played anakin skywalker
in attack of the clones and revenge of
the sith was confirmed to co-star as
darth vader in the upcoming series back
in 2020. lucasfilm president kathleen
kennedy promised christensen's return to
star wars would result in the rematch of
the century between vader and kenobi
given the heavy presence within the
trailer of the empire's inquisitors it's
probably safe to say vader will oversee
their efforts to find kenobi in october
2021 the hollywood reporter also
reported that the now 40 year old actor
will also reprise his role as darth
vader in the upcoming series ahsoka
alongside rosario dawson ahsoka tano and
anakin skywalker grew close as jedi
padawan and master through star wars the
clone wars making the upcoming series a
second long-awaited reunion between fan
favorites as for what role vader plays
in the future of obi-wan kenobi that
still remains to be seen well sort of
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]